على متن طائره كنديه قادمه من تورنتو الى
اتلانتا تعرض هذا الشاب لاعتداء مفاجئ حيث
روى تفاصيل الحادث لمراسله سانان التي
كانت تجلس بالقرب منه وقال الشاب الذي
يدعى اوليفر منايل انه وبينما كان نائما
اثناء الرحله شعر بشيء ما يلتف حول عنقه
حيث اقدم احد الركاب على لف سلك معدني حول
رقبته محاولا خلقه وتمكن ميتال من ابعاد
الحبل عن بعدما هرع عدد من الركاب
للمساعده حيث اجبر المهاجم على البقاء
جالسا مع ربط حزام الامان طوال
الرح وفي كل مره كان يحاول مغادره مقعده
واجهه الركاب بالصراخ وطلب العوده الى
مقعده ولدى هبوط الطائره اعتقلت الشرطه
المشتبهه فيه واقتادته لاجراء تقييم طبي
عقلي له في حين قال مكتب التحقيقات
الفدرالي انه لا يوجد حاليا اي اتهامات
اتحاديه
ضده